depuis la rentrée l'éducation nationale
met en oeuvre tout un dispositif de
prévention de la violence mais aussi de
l'échec scolaire dans les établissements
dits sensibles
une mission d'inspection va
prochainement examiner le classement en
zone sensible précisément d'un collège
de beauvais
fermé depuis près de trois semaines en
raison du climat d'insécurité qui règne
reportage valérie astruc pierre laurent
constant vide plus de cours depuis trois
semaines les élèves du collège henri
dumont livrés à eux mêmes leurs parents
décidé de ne plus les envoyer en classe
à l'origine l'agression d'un prof de gym
par un élève de sixième parfois on ne
passe plus pour les parents la coupe est
pleine depuis la rentrée
soixante dix élèves victimes
d'agressions sont passés par
l'infirmerie la violence dans le collège
est devenu points c'est ça va deux
fronts
enfin des comportements quand même très
spécifique décidé petits-enfants dont il
n'arrive à se déshabiller en cours et se
livraient des pratique masturbatoire 1/6
évidemment c'est quand même assez
étonnant enseignants des parents
réclament donc que le collège soit
classé en zone sensible
nous voulons ou des professeurs en plus
voire dédoubler les classes pour pouvoir
apporter aux jeunes et aux autres
peuples leur apporter aux enfants qui
sont en difficulté scolaire et pour
pouvoir apporter également aux enfants
qui travaille bien qui sont en demande
et qu'ils seront aussi nombreux dans cet
établissement
une assistante sociale quatre ans point
ville un poste de surveillant ont d'ores
et déjà été débloqués le collège est
suffisamment doté estime le rectorat qui
réclament à présent que les cours
reprennent au plus vite